we don't usually do this but I'm going
green today so I'm going to recycle
words you've probably already heard
mainly because they're better than
anything I could come up with you have
stolen my dreams in my childhood with
your empty words yet I'm one of the
lucky ones people are suffering people
are dying
entire ecosystems are collapsing we are
in the beginning of a mass extinction
and all you can talk about is the money
and fairy tales of eternal economic
growth how dare you like fine
but today the grown-ups struck back with
one French Minister criticizing 16 year
old for despair verging on hatred and
Chancellor Merkel ticking her off for
ignoring the potential of green
technology I'm not a massive fan of
extinction rebellion I think they're
dangerous extremists but Greta Thumb
Berg has every right to be furious at
the world leaders who patted her on the
head and then did precisely nothing
about her demand if they really
respected young people they'd start a
serious debate about the real brutal
choices that we face we should be
talking about a carbon allowance that
limits every households car usage
central heating electricity and
consumption of meat with a hundred
percent tax on any energy used beyond
that limit a trump sal ban on 119
billion dollars worth of cheap clothes
exported by the coal-fired chinese red
trade every year and what about the
population growth but Sir David
Attenborough says is the biggest risk to
the planet how about imposing a
one-child policy on the world's
fastest-growing regions Africa and the
Middle East
everything else is hot air will the next
generation really give up cars clothes
and the right to have children I'm
skeptical
[Music]
I love it love it
honestly I mean I agree with you I think
that I do I absolutely agree with Trevor
I think we're reaching a point where we
need actually a sort of war effort it's
we're in the middle of a mass extinction
event and all we're doing is talking
about brexit it's nonsense
I mean I want brexit done in order we
can really talk about the important
stuff and how we need to do much more on
an individual level and on our
governmental level to address this
potentially planetary event that there's
coming down the track let's so glad I
said that population control of course
we have to talk about population control
and world leaders have to say this loud
and clear the biggest thing we need
David Attenborough to say every day but
sorry can we just hear what the global
lead on climate change Action Aid Harjit
Singh says in response to all this which
is this summit was supposed to be a
turning point but we have seen an
exceptional lack of commitment from the
biggest and richest polluting countries
that continue to take trivial measures
towards solving a life-or-death crisis
I'm going to come to Nick because I have
a feeling that if I don't he will be an
extinction of this student well welcome
to the world of Chairman trevor and
queen of the court is obviously queen
rho1 child policy really so we've been
in opposition others has many children I
really don't know you talk about look
the passion displayed by Greta Sundberg
is to be only but admired but let's just
row back you've destroyed my dreams
you've destroyed my childhood she's 16
there's a mass extinction story that
makes it sound like the Khmer Rouge or
the Holocaust are there issues to
address yes there are has she gone too
far
and during the politician sing it yes
she has because she is frightening other
children I did this on my radio show and
it's amazing how many parents are saying
but their children possibly don't want
your mother and because they think the
planet is coming to an end it's not look
how much of advance in outer just in my
lifetime
almost we've had the NHS we've had some
sort of drugs that keep people alive we
flow people to the moon hold on
so we are genuinely genuinely
frightening the children and we have to
be very aware of it and one other thing
you make the point you made the point
about coal-fired stations making these
cheap clothes who are the people who buy
these cheap clothes mostly
sixteen-year-old girls who go to primer
or TK Maxx or Matalin and throw the
bloody thing baby this is exactly my
point
if what if we're going to take young
people seriously let us engage with the
actual point they're making with which I
have a great deal of sympathy but let's
not just Pat them on the head and say oh
that was very well expressed let us
treat them seriously enough for us to
talk to them about right the real
consequences of this are going to be and
the real choice is otherwise actually
we'll still be having this conversation
you know 20 years on when the Maldives
and by the way the country when my
family comes from Guyana is under water
but Trevor I'm fairly pessimistic I'm a
bit like her I fell officially and the
reason that pessimistic is we live in
democracies and democracies the people
who win in democracies are people who
actually promise economic growth they
promise better for most people now
this is not possible in the world of her
of her world it's not possible that you
can happen she said you can't have this
never-ending economic growth and yet no
politician is going to stand up and say
you can't have any let me go if you've
got it you can only have one holiday
every five years outside the country
you're gonna no one is gonna do it and
therefore will make small we'll all make
some changes in that case we shouldn't
have UN summits they should just shut up
instead of pretending that they're doing
something this is exactly why we'll get
to the place that we started this
program with we're actually there is a
massive problem everybody knows it's a
massive problem everybody shouts it's a
massive problem and then we produce a
little mouse to deal with it and the
puppet and the population says what are
you for this is how we get
disillusionment
this is how people think not solved
are you prepared to dramatically change
your life well if I think if now yeah
the answer to that Gregg is yes if I am
sure what I think I'm gonna get on
holiday out beside the country anymore
well what I think would happen is that I
have to pay a lot more yeah and I'm
happy with that you have to have a
flight quota it's not but that in itself
means that the poor suffer yes maybe let
me show you describe that speech as
electrifying I just thought was a bit
weird
I find it now I do I understand the
sentiment but I'm I just find it
slightly exploitative when I think of
Gretta I understand climate change is a
huge issue I do I understand that
actually we need to be doing something
about it but we're just missing for me
the fundamental basic building blocks
because if we look at what can we do yes
of course these humongous initiatives
need to be taking place but on a daily
basis there are a genuine small little
thing is that we could be doing as a
household so most people don't even
understand what they are don't you meet
that what our example I'm gonna eat a
cheeseburger if I want a cheeseburger
I'm not sure it's not only the end of
days no I eat them a lot less these days
than I used to it so I'm doing my know
why can we just talk about me for a
second because methane is 34 times more
destructive for the ozone there than co2
so methane is a serious issue Nuffield
coming out on both ends of town
if we did cut down on meat it would
bring home the bacon in terms of our
carbon target reductions we gotta
educate households can be doing well I
was having this discussion yeah and
someone running a bunch of hotels the
other day and they said if you look at
hotels today if you look at people
coming in to eat it's about 50% of still
order a steak and and a great chunk
still order burgers though it hasn't
it's got soot of certain people but it
has not gone through to the people it's
gone mostly well-off people and as I'm
saying in the end it requires
governments to do terribly unpopular
things and governments don't do that
thank you Greg this is essential my
point is essentially one about politics
it is we have to
stop saying to people the problem is
gigantic and I am going to solve it
vote for me and then produce results
that look like that because that is why
people are losing faith in democracy
that's why Putin and birdy and Watson
are on these strong this is why I share
just how this little stronger your one
child policy remind me the democracy
there well I great I mean it was your
idea my point my point is if you want to
do something I mean of course this is
one of the things about China I would
never ever want to live under the
Chinese regime but they are clear they
know what scale of their problem is so
actually they are just doing things
which are unthinkable a week indeed
they're do my point is they are don't
define a problem and then they apply a
solution which is of the right sketches
you come through in China obviously no
Putnam chair there and all party Select
Committee for House of Lords and House
of Commons on climate change he invited
the Chinese to come and give evidence
they came and gave evidence and they
said we don't understand much because we
know there's a problem
and we will do something about it
because of our system of government you
won't and I'm afraid that democracy
doesn't know how to cope with it
yeah and there's no democracy here
between because stop this summer saw a
master class of sporting prowess and I
think the team are having sport with me
here by the way from Coco Goff smashing
it at Wimbledon to Tiger Woods first
major win in 11 years it's been one for
the history books
now while there were many standout
moments there's one event that topped
them all a personal favorite of mine it
says here the Women's World Cup yes the
competition might have lacked a super
over but it broke barriers as well as
records and grabbed the attention of the
nation but as its outspoken poster girl
Megan Rupe Oney reminded us football
still has a long way to go to become
truly inclusive in an acceptance speech
like know whether the u.s. forward urged
everyone to change the
for the better but the FIFA best Awards
in Milan this week if we really want to
have meaningful change but what I think
is most inspiring would be if everybody
other than Raheem Sterling and coulibaly
if they were as outraged about racism as
they were if everybody else was that if
everybody was as outraged about
homophobia as the LGBTQ players as if
everybody was as outraged about equal
pay or the lack thereof or the lack of
investment in the women's game other
than just women that would be the most
inspiring thing to me back of the net
for striking like that and giving us the
kick up the ass we needed Megan it says
here you are our straight talker of the
week
now you might tell Rachel a little bit
you're delighted are you she doesn't
know what you're doing there by the way
it's wrapped in no sorry I apologize
it's a superstar women's soccer go
forward oh yes move forward still a long
way behind but it's move fall very
quickly in this country I mean what
you're telling me it's a different era
it's a fantastic game I mean actually I
my eyes were opened okay if I have a
whistle I blow it because that's all
we've got time for this week but if you
want to join in the debate just search
for the pledge on Twitter and don't
forget you can take the debate with you
by listening to us on Apple podcasts
Spotify or whichever app you prefer
thank you for watching
[Music]